hey guys this is andrew for trading
senses.com
and in this video i want to talk about
golden rule number three
which is do not follow the herd
let's get into it
[Music]
so guys for those who don't know me yet
my name is andrew
actually andrew is a nickname but
whatever and i have already made
two videos on golden rule number one
which is to have a good strict and
proper
risk management and golden rule number
two
which is to have discipline which is
actually the only way
to follow your risk management so those
are the very important rules that you
guys
should to know to be aware of so invite
you guys to go to see those videos first
if you haven't seen it yet now golden
rule number three
do not follow the herd what does it mean
it's very simple it basically means
do not listen to what people are saying
around you
all right because nobody knows i don't
know
you don't know we only think
but what i can tell you is that usually
when people
actually you know don't do the effort to
use some techniques they don't work
on you know their um views
on what they really think the market
would do
they just repeat what they hear you know
i don't know if you guys you know
know some people like this but we all do
you know those guys that you know they
pretend
they think something but they just heard
it in the in the radio or on the tv on
the internet they read it somewhere
in the same morning and they just repeat
it like if it was their story
laughing like if it was their view all
right so there are ships
guys there are ships and they do not
think
i i'm not saying those guys can't think
i'm just saying that there are a lot of
people that like to talk and like just
talking things
that they don't think personally so do
not listen to them
and another reason you should not listen
to um
people around you is that as i said
we are all humans we have emotions
we have emotions and our our emotions
they are not random i mean the the
impact of our emotions on the
on our view of the market is not random
is
actually um making us
think the wrong way you know so if we
get rid of our emotions we are better
you know that's for sure i'm gonna show
you a few examples
why i think our emotions impact our view
of the market
negatively i mean that we usually should
think the other way around so for
example
when um we have a bull market
usually during the bull market there are
a lot of people that say oh it's too
much extended you know it's going too
high
it's there is no good reasons for this
bull market to happen you know stuff
like
this and this usually is the third wave
it's when the smart
money is actually uh invested those are
hedge funds
getting in strongly because it's
actually the right time to buy
during the third wave because it's very
impulsive it's very
surprising but actually it's expected
and and then you have the false waves or
correction and then it goes
higher again and then those guys that
were saying all the time
it can't go higher it can't go higher
then suddenly
they change their mind you know it's
funny but this
this is what is happening and this is
the fifth wave of illiot wave uh
formation and by the way for those who
don't know what is iliot wave
principle i invite you guys to click on
the link in my in the description of the
video
and you're gonna receive a free video uh
on where i explain
everything i mean the best i can about
ralph ellison
eliot who is just amazing whatever
so the fifth wave of idiot wave
formation is usually when you have the
more
the most greed people are greedy you
know they see
people around them making money and they
are just like feeling why not me
uh because usually those guys they
didn't buy the third wave you know and
they they just you know it's pure formal
you know fear of missing out
and they just see people making money
and they want to be part of it
and then greed is coming and they're all
gonna say
this is bullish this market is bullish
watch out guys this is usually
when uh actually the bullish uh trend
is about to be finished all right fifth
wave of idiot reformation
so basically the grid uh is making you
uh fearless and and bullish for bad
reasons
we can see it the other way around all
right uh
when the market is dropping heavily like
really heavily
those are usually c wave of a zigzag or
flat correction of idiot wave
principle the c wave is usually
devastating
is the most severe
and and hard correction that
happens in those corrections uh in those
corrections
all right um and then what do you have
what is the feeling
guys what is the feeling it's fear that
is then transformed into some sort of
panic
you don't think right and everybody
usually you know they're holding
between the a wave so zigzag is a b c
during the a wave they're holding you
know they're like no it's okay it's just
correcting like 10 20
it's gonna come back higher as it always
does then you have the b
wave all right and once again the b wave
is the time to escape guys
usually uh and the c wave starts
again so it can be like six months six
months six months or you know 18 months
of correction
like we had for example in 2008 and the
c wave
was actually expected but still it
surprised a lot of investors
that thought the the worst has been
behind them
and actually the worst was coming and
what happens then
you know you come you start to get the
the price starts to trade lower
and you go below the the bottom of
a of wave a then how do you feel you
feel like oh [ __ ]
i should have escaped when i could but
then you're like all right i'm in it i
stay in it
and then it goes lower lower and then
you have despair
you know people are just desperated and
and usually when the sea wave is very
long you know and it's just like
ruining your your mental uh you know
you feel very bad uh and your emotions
are
very going against the right decision
you should take
and usually before the end of sea wave
what happens
you have what we call capitulation is
like too much
you know you suffered too much it's been
too long you're losing money it's been
too long
you could have uh get get out of the
tread you
are wiped out if you if you don't have a
proper stop loss and you are still in
the trade
you are wiped out you don't have a lot
of money uh
that is still here but if it's a buy and
hold strategy with nola veg all right
you see guys that you're not gonna sell
but if you have some leverage and you
didn't put your stop loss properly so we
come back to
uh golden rule number one put your
stop-loss where it should be
and depending on how much you can lose
and invest uh then
usually you're gonna um take the worst
decision ever
just before the end of seawave you know
this is what is usually happening you
know retail investors
they usually sell at this moment who is
buying
professionals all right hedge funds for
example because they know how things
happen
and they're gonna buy massively and then
the market is gonna revert this is what
happened in 2009 guys
um so just everything uh
i said all of this to explain to you
guys that you should not listen to what
is
said around you all right because of
greed because of panic because of fear
because of all these emotions people
usually
don't say um good advice all right
so stick to your plan uh and do not
change anything because people just
repeat what they heard
that's it for me for golden rule number
three do not follow the herd i hope
this helps you guys and if it did please
like the video and hit the subscribe
button
and stay close to show i see you guys